c'est des vrais d'accord tu veux faire
quoi en fait tu veux rester tu veux
partir ah moi je veux juste pas faire
une crise de non mais part c'est mieux
bah vous êtes trois potes bah très bien
allez ah bah quatre potes et ben
barrez-vous allez
[Applaudissements]
merci hier l'enquête a pris un tournant
puisquune information judiciaire été
ouverte pour enlèvement ou séquestration
de plus de 7 jours
alors
pourquoi pourquoi pour avoir un cadre
juridique qui permette aux enquêteurs
j'ai envie de dire presque enfin de
trava normalement voilà parce que avant
c'était pas c'était plus compliqué quand
ils sont dans le dans le premier cadre
ça permet de déclencher plus de moyens
en fait he pour les téléspectateurs
c'est pour ça que c'est important que ça
ce tournant dans cette information
judiciaire plus de moyens vite
c'està-dire des enquêtes multipliées des
procédures multipliées possibilité de
mettre sur écoute plein de gens sans
tergiverser donc voilà beaucoup plus de
moyens vous l'avez dit ça veut dire
aussi puisque ils ont dit que ça se
couplait sans doute d'une action de
longue Aline ça veut dire qu'ils ont
encore ouvert toutes les pistes mais
qu'ils écartent maintenant en avec ce
chef là ils écartent quand même de plus
en plus la piste de la disparition
volontaire et de l'accident il quelque
chose c'est surtout qu'il pouvait pas
faire de garde à vue il pouvait pas
mettre des gens en garde à vue dans le
premier cadre qui qui avait été retenu
donc sur une affaire comme ça à partir
du moment où c'est pas une fugue c'est
forcément criminel et si c'est criminel
faut avoir les moyens de pouvoir placer
un suspect en garde à vue la troisème
info sur la faire Lina samedi les
enquêteurs ont été orientés sur une
fausse piste qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
alors euh les enquêteurs ont
effectivement
été ont reçu un appel téléphonique en
leur disant qu' ferait bien d'aller
chercher un endroit précis qui est sur
le chemin d'ailleurs c'est sur le bas
côté de qui cet appel je ça je pas
l'information mais c'est peut-être un
appel anonyme c'est peut-être de
quelqu'un qui leur a dit faut c'est ça
qui est fou donc ça déjà c'est quand
même ça veut dire que ouais il a
quelqu'un qui a appelé les enquêteurs et
qui leur a dit d'aller chercher un
endroit précis quel endroit ça ça arrive
ça arrive souvent euh l'endroit c'est
sur le sur le bord de cette de cette
route départementale et comme les
enquêteurs sont obligés bien évidemment
de tout vérifier ils ont pris les moyens
nécessaire pour vérifier ils ont creusé
avec un un outil un
tractopel ils ont extrait des Ossem
c'est ça et il s'est avéré que c'était
des ossements anim de nature animale an
qui est quand même fou Gill euh parce
que il y a un appel une personne dit
d'aller chercher là-bas il trouve des
OSM oui donc là quand on a vu qu'ils
avaient trouvé des osems on s'est tous
dit bah catastrophe ou et finalement non
euh finalement c'est c'est c'est c'est
pas ça c'est des EOS d'animaux la police
scientifique et technique est venue sur
place mais vous imaginez comme les
autorités ont dit appelez-nous surtout
nous attendons des appels pour tout et
presque pour rien même si vous étiez là
et que vous n'avez rien vu ça va nous
aider donc du coup tout le monde appelle
et chaque témoignage donne lieu à un
acte de procédure ils veulent rien
laisser au hasard mais oui mais comment
ça c'est c'est une fausse piste une
fausse piste il y en a plein de fausse
piste ça s'appelle une piste fermé mais
on va au bout pour vérifier voilà c'est
d'origine animale donc la piste se
referme sur
elle-même 4e info sur cette enquête et
importante ce weekend il y a il y a
aussi une maison inspectée de fond enc
par les enquêteurs qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette maison alors c'est une maison
occupée par un pourquoi c'est surtout la
voiture je pense surtout qu'il a pris
les choses de haut qu'il a pas calculé
en fait le le les les inconvénients
qu'il pouvait y avoir à ne pas prendre
au sérieux la démarche des gendarmes il
habite à 5 km du lieu de la disparition
et c'est vrai qu'il a pas fourni une
explication cohérente sur son emploi du
temps donc les enquêteurs ont été
attirés parce que la voiture ce monsieur
qui ne donne pas vraiment son emploi du
temps ils se sont dit tiens et donc ils
ont fait venir ce qu'on appelle l'IRCGN
c'est les techniciens scientifiques de
la gendarmerie qui sont région
parisienne et ils se sont intéressés
aussi à lui parce que il était dans le
secteur de la disparition de Lina le
jour où il a où elle a disparu et que sa
voiture est une Renau Clio de couleur
bleu nuit voilà donc il était aussi dans
le dans les parages oui oui il les
intéressent c'est une personne qui n'est
pas suspecté du tout mais qui les
intéresse parce que il y a des
incohérences dans son premier témoignage
semble-t-il voilà alors il a été
auditionné par les gendarmes oui alors
il a été entendu mais comme il pouvait
pas faire de garde à vue donc ils l'ont
entendu de façon libre alors il pouvaiit
pas faire de garde à vue parce que parce
qu'ils avaient pas le cadre juridique
pour le faire exactement justement donc
là depuis euh il pourrait il pourrait
faire une Guer d' oui là ils l'ont
entendu visiblement cette piste est en
train de se refermer mais en tout cas il
a quand même eu des ennuis de sérieux
ennuis ce professeur de musique euh on
pendant 3 jours vendredi samedi il y a
eu des fouilles perquisitions à son
domicile avec des polices des gendarmes
de la police technique et scientifique
et comme si ça suffisait pas on a mis
les C sur la maison donc comme il était
pas en garde à vue il était libre et
donc il a été obligé d'aller dormir
ailleurs et on a mis deux gendarmes
devant la maison pour être sûr qu' qu'il
rentre pas malgré les scellé et le
dimanche c'est l'IRCGN donc
qu'évoquait Gilles qui sont venus
parachever le travail de de vérification
donc Blu star ils ont à mon avis ils ont
passé la maison au peignef P 3 jours et
l'info la plus importante du weekend
après on va revenir bien sûr sur aussi
le petit ami de de de Lina l'événement
du weekend c'est le témoignage de Robert
alors ça ça a été un tournom dans
l'enquête qui affirme avoir vu Lina
passer devant chez lui le jour de sa
disparition dans une voiture qu'est-ce
que c'est qui est Robert déjà et
qu'est-ce que c'est cette histoire
robert est un retraité il a 72 ans il
habite à la plaine il connaît Lina parce
qu'il est client de la suérette où elle
travaille en
alternance donc au en centre au centre
du village euh et lui dit un peu
tardivement mais il le dit quand même
euh qu'il était sorti de de sa maison
pour fumer un cigare et qui a vu passer
à ce moment-là donc un horaire qui est
qui est entre 11h et 11h30 il aurait vu
Lina passagère d'un véhicule bleu qui
roulait à à l'opposé c'estd qui prenait
la direction de la plaine il fait la
description vestimentaire de Lina en
disant qu'elle avait un haut blanc enfin
clair en tout cas euh qu'elle avait pas
l'air sous contraint al l' histoire
c'est qu'elle lui aurait fait un coucou
en passant et elle aurait eu l'air
normal et n'avait pas l'air soucieuse
selon lui c'est un témoignage qui
incroyable REM met beaucoup de choses en
en question il bouge vertout elle lui
fait un signe il la connaît il la voit
vous l'avez obligé à l'emmener vers
Strasbourg voilà qui était sa
destination en train pour retrouver son
petit ami donc voilà donc il intéresse
beaucoup les enquêteurs il est très
crédible très précis c'est vrai que ça
vient avec quelques jours de retard ce
témoignage c'est le seul point faible
mais sinon il y a beaucoup de point
les journalist sont rend compte qu'il
ven de capter un témoignage cl regardez
par c'est limite un hasard incroyable
regardez je l'ai vu passer là dans une
voiture bleue elle est habillée en clair
qu'elle a fait coucou en passant mais
elle avait l'air normal elle avait pas
l'air d'être soucieuse ou quoi que ce
soit pas fait de d'appel ni quoi que ce
soit il y avait un monsieur à côté donc
qui roulait qu'elle venait de là-bas la
route de seur vers plein
cette route mène à Strasbourg les
inv alors il a fait une description
derrière de de l'individu qui était dans
la voiture mais c'est vrai qu'elle est
assz flou flou et les gendarmes l'ont
entendu 3 He quand même preuve qu'il
prennent ça très au sérieux le témoage
poignant c'est peutre celui de sa
grand-mère qui a voulu adresser un
message au potentiel ravissur de Lina et
juste après parlera de ta le petit ami
parce qu'on en a beaucoup parlé jeudi et
voilà Onir où ça
est j'ai une chose à dire que ma petite
fille revienne au plus
vite on
attend les bras le cœur grand ouvert on
l'attend on veut qu'on nous la rende
notre petite chérie on veut qu'on nous
la rende notre
gamine voilà donc beaucoup d'émotion et
puis a la maman regardez je juste vous
montrer la maman avant qu'on parle de
Tao le petit ami Fanny la maman Lina qui
est dévastée mais combattiv
regardez comment vous vous sentez en
tant que maman mal déchiré
broyer il y a pas de mot je lâche rien
je peut-être ouais la rage la rage de
retrouver ma fille qui qui qui m'aide à
avancer qui qui fait que je me je me
bats je me bats parce que là elle a
besoin de moi et que c'est pas le moment
de flancher j'espère vraiment du fond de
mon cœur qu'elle sens ce lien qui qui
nous rattache et je je lui envoie tout
je
bat-toi garde espoir on est là on lâche
rien on te
cherche c'est mainant depu 23 septembre
alors écoutez aussi Sarah qui est la
dernière amie à avoir parlé avec Lina et
elle va montrer les messages qu'elle lui
a envoyé mais qui sont malheureusement
rester sans réponse regardez c'est un
chemin qu'elle empreinte assez souvent
pour aller à Strasbourg alors soit c'est
une personne qui l'avait déjà repéré
qu'elle croisait déjà souvent et que ce
jour-là bah la personne a décidé de
passer à l'action comment la personne
aurait pu savoir qu'elle va à la gare
surtout c'est ça qui qui est bizarre
malgré sa disparition S ne cesse
d'envoyer des messages à son ami je dis
Lina s'il te plaît réponds s'il te plaît
s'il te plaît j'ai peur réponds je
t'aime réponds je l'ai appelé trois fois
reviens on t'aime allez un pe for s'il
te
plaît extrêmement bien sûr poignant ce
qu'on voit
alors on voit qu'elle a fait un coucou
donc monsieur qui a croisé donc qui
supposer que si c'est vrai elle
connaîtrait la personne avec qui était
dans la voiture oui qu'elle la
connaîtrait et que c'est sans doute
quelqu'un de confiance c'est plut ça la
thèse voilà c'estàdire qu'elle elle est
pas du tout apeurée elle est
souriante donc ça intrigue beaucoup
parce que ça va à l'encontre des
premiers témoignages mais néanmoins
quelqu'un qui la reconnaît alors qu'on
perd sa trace c'est un élément tangible
sur la voiture est-ce qu'on est sûr de
la marque non alors il y a un doute un
peu sur la marque on a parlé d'une Clio
je cite la marque non non non non non il
y a deux véhicules distincts qui ont été
cités c'est là où ça va pas on a un un
premier témoins qui voit une Clio donc
c'est le le monsieur de 72 ans Robert et
euh l'autre témoin le la la petite
Karine qu'on appelle Karine qui elle
voit une une Xantia grise elle va même
la photographier la XANA grise est-ce
que les couleurs sont les mêmes alors
non il y en a une qui est grise c'est la
Xantia et la Clio est bleue il y a
saufaginez qu'il y a deux prédateurs
dans ce petit village de 900 habitants
après bleu nuit gris voilà la marque de
la voiture voilà je pense que c'est
uneti une cl m oua franchement je vous
dis on sa voilà c'est possible c'est pas
des concessionnaires non plus je suis
pas expert aut Robert lui ne sait pas
exactement quelle est la marque de la
voiture dans laquelle il aurait vu mais
il parle d'une voiture bleu bleu bleu
oua alors jeudi dernier vous étiez
revenu nous parler de de plusieurs voilà
de plusieurs questionnements autour de
Taou le petit ami de Lina son téléphone
perdu on le rappelle son changement de
plan à la dernière minute son
comportement auprès de Zoé qui était
venu sur notre plateau il lui avait dit
ne dis pas de conneries je préviens où
ça en est avec Tao écoutez Tao a a
tweeté ou envoyé des des messages
notment à la rédaction du du du journal
où il confirme tout ce que j'ai dit sur
le plateau mais de toute façon ce que
j'ai dit sur le plateau c'était pas
accablant pour lui c'était simplement
des éléments de vous a dit quoi
d'information vous a écrit quoi Tao Tao
j'ai j'ai pas j'ai pas a eu le le le le
contenu exact du du tweet mais il est
d'une part en colère contre moi mais en
même temps il confirme ce que j'ai dit
donc allz y comprendre quelque chose lui
il dit qu'il a été vu à Strasbourg que
voilà queil y était bien à ce moment-là
c'est ce qu'il a dit érieurement mais
mais non non mais je dis pas du tout que
vous avez dit le contraire c'est ce que
dit lui il dit je j'étais à Strasbourg à
ce moment-là donc il faut rappeler qu'il
n'est pas suspect à l'heure actuelle
personne d'ailleurs n'est suspect et le
problème des enquêteurs c'est qu'il y a
pas d'élément matériel donc toutes les
pistes sont ouvertes ils enquêtent on le
voit tout asimute partout mais pour le
moment il y a pas un élément matériel
qui leur ferait dire tiens c'est cette
piste là vers laquelle on va aller c'est
ça le gros problème voilà alors et et
donc Tao nous je crois que la rédaction
l'a eu également le petit ami de de Dina
et et voilà il a dit qu'il avait été
qu'il est forcément bien sûr sous sous
tension voilà avec tout ce qui se passe
et que c'est c'est sa petite amie voilà
qui a disparu donc forcément voilà quand
est venu sur le plateau il lu a juste
demandé de pas dire de conneries parce
que il voulait pas voilà que l'enquête
soit voilà
euh voilà fagocité par des mauvaises
informations et cetera même si Zoé a été
incroyable mais voilà il nous a dit
voilà qu'il était forcément assez
nerveux et que jour chaque minute qui
passe pour lui ce sont des heures des
jours entiers que Tao forcément il a
envie de retrouver sa petite amie et que
il dit moi je suis je suis avec les
parents et la famille celui qui qui
souffre le plus actuellement et
forcément j'ai pas un comportement euh
voilà habituel voilà il dit aujourd'hui
voilà je sais pas où est où est Lina
elle a disparu alors que j'avais
rendez-vous avec elle donc forcément je
peux pas avir un comportement normal oui
je pense qu'il a été maladroit dans ses
propos c'est tout
mais qu'il me pardonne si jamais je l'ai
blessé c'était pas du tout mon mon
intention je voulais juste donner des
informations qui sont d'ailleurs pas
contredites par le part
Tao c'est toi la
principale ben écoute je vais dire ce
que je pense je passe mon temps ici à
dire que euh bah aux jeunes filles aux
jeunes femmes que il faut rien laisser
passer que tous les les gestes
inappropriés bah il faut absolument
immédiatement le dire donc je vais pas
me dédire effectivement j'ai détesté le
geste d'Alex voilà je nai pas j'ai pas
aimé c'est un geste totalement
inapproprié et en même temps j'ai
détesté ma réaction parce que sur le
moment bah j'ai pas su réagir ah ouais
j'ai pas su réagir euh et donc ça fait
penser aux autres femmes qui savent pas
forcément toujours réagir on est dans un
contexte particulier il y a un plateau
de télé il y a des gens qui rient je ne
sais pas si moi j'ai bien vécu ce que
j'ai vécu et c'est pour ça que je
voulais te remercier Cyril parce que tu
as validé ce que moi j'avais vécu
c'est-à-dire que comme tu l'as vu aussi
tu as immédiatement pardon je te tutoie
mais vous avez immédiatement dit tutoyer
vous avez immédiatement dit stop ça ne
se fait pas et par cette chose-l vous
avez validé ce que je ressentais à ce
moment-là j'ai que toi tu t'en a même
pas rendu compte c'est si si je m'en
suis tout à fait rendu compte non non je
m'en suis tout à fait rendu compte mais
euh bah on moi mon mécanisme de défense
c'est de c'est de rire donc je mets à
distance en riant immédiatement donc
j'ai mis à distance en riant
immédiatement et par le fait de dire
vous Cyril stop là tu tu es complètement
taré qu'est-ce que tu fais ça a validé
mon ressenti et le fait de le valider je
voudrais dire d'ailleurs à tous les gens
euh la réaction de Cyril elle est elle
est parfaite et quand vous voyez quelque
chose qui vous semble inapproprié osez
le dire parce que ça peut aider la
personne qui le vit à ce moment-là parce
que on est à même nous de se dire mais
est-ce que j'en fais des caisses est-ce
que c'est trop est-ce que c'est moi qui
surréagis est-ce que voilà donc euh vrai
merci alors on s soir après on va le
dire on s' on'en a parlé après et
évidemment j'en ai parlé avec Alex qui
immédiatement lui sur le coup ne s'en
est pas rendu compte et au fur et à
mesure s'en est rendu compte et on en a
on a échangé beaucoup ce qui important
c'est dans quel comment Alex l'a fait
est-ce qu'il y avait une intention
malveillante il y avait aucune intention
malveillante de sa part j'en suis
absolument persuadé depuis ça a été un
voilà on en a beaucoup parlé il était
dévasté il m'a offert un bouquet de
fleurs je vais pas révéler la tenneur de
nos échanges mais on a eu des échanges
voilà de en voilà en toute transparence
et sur nos nos nos vécus respectifs euh
excuse accepté euh voilà à faire close
je voudrais juste ajouter une petite
chose ce qui est intéressant c'est que
dès la fin de l'émission j'ai vu la
charge inversée c'est-à-dire que j'étais
enfin évidemment Alex a vécu plein de
choses mais de mon côté j'ai été sommé
par les réseaux sociaux par tout le
monde de de réagir de commenter et où
j'en faisais trop où j'en faisais pas
assez alors d'un côté j'en faisais pas
assez parce que j'avais rit et faut pas
rire mais on se débrouille on fait comme
on peut hein pardon et de l'autre côté
j'en faisais trop parce que bon ça va
c'est juste une main au cul bah en fait
on fait comme on peut et on fait comme
on veut je dis à toutes F comme on peut
et on fait comme on veut bravoà et je
voudrais dire parce que moi voilà c'est
passé c'est voilà et et vraiment encore
une fois excuse accepté Alex on passe à
autre chose mais je pense à des femmes
qui onag votre compagnon vous en a parlé
bien sûr compagnon mon fils mon père oui
c'est pas ma mère euh ça restera entre
nous ils étaient pas un moment qui est
pas agréable pour eux parce qu' ils
savaient que c'était pas un moment
agréable pour
moi mais juste je voudrais terminer sur
sur ça juste dire aux jeunes femmes qui
qui qui nous regardent qui et qui ont
vécu des choses qui n'ont rien à voir he
qui sont à des degrés voilà parce qu'il
y a des hiérarchies aussi dans ce qu'on
puis il y a des gens qui le font exprès
et d'autres qui le font pas exprès voilà
mais en l'occurrence voilà vous faites
comme vous voulez vous faites comme vous
pouvez et personne n'a de mots à dire
sur ce que vous dites ou ce que vous
faites voilà alex est avec nous Alex euh
merci Alex qui alors c'est vrai qu'on a
pas de Magneto donc merci Alex d'être là
merci je sais que c'est pas évident
merci mon merci merci ass-toi c'est toi
c'est toi mon chéri voilà donc c'est
vrai
que voilà Valérie et vous et toi vous
êtes beaucoup parlé j'ai vu Alex que
depuis depuis ce qui s'est passé depuis
retour sur la séquence est-ce que dès
dès le début de la séquence tu t'es dit
[__] j'ai merdi en fait sur le moment
si tu veux je peux trouver tous les
excuses de la terre c'està dire on
faisait une danse de couple Chomo je
voulais faire un mouvement de Dan avec
les star mais en fait la vérité c'est
que toutes les excuses de la terre sont
bidon tu vois voà c'est inadmissible
c'est pas normal j'aurais jamais dû
faire ça je sais pas ce qui m'a pris je
n'ai même jamais fait ce Gest là dans ma
vie à personne ever ça te ressemble pas
du tout àex je n'ai jamais fait ça même
dans ma vie même à mes mecs j'ai jamais
fait ça ça m'est jamais arrivé donc je
voilà je sais pas c'est un pétage de
câble comme d'ailleurs sur le moment
voilà donc je après tu tu comprends
l'ampleur du truc parce que c'est le
monde dans lequel on vit je suis rentré
chez moi ben j'ai pas dormi j'ai pas DMI
pendant 3 jours d'ailleurs donc c'est
aussi simple ça été quoi pendant 3 jours
bah mais c'est comme ça et c'est mérité
quelque part si tu veux c'est juste que
la dimension est tellement immense entre
les menaces de mort les machin tout mais
mais je suis pas la victime je suis le
bourreau donc je vais pas te dire que
c'est compliqué dans dans l'absolu
évidemment que c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué pour ma famille pour mes
proches mais c'est tout aussi compliqué
pour Valérie d'avoir encore les images
qui sont partout balancées dans tous les
sens parce que les réseaux c'est comme
ça il y a des mêmes il y a des machins
parmi les images moi ça part partout je
te remercie beaucoup et merci déjà de de
me faire venir mais voilà après la réité
c'est que j'ai 50 p j'apprends encore
des trucs auj aujourd'hui et et c'est
bien d' encore apprendre mais si j'avais
pu éviter d'apprendre comme ça ça aurait
été très bien et je me suis déjà excusé
bon mais qu'est-ce que tu dis depuis
depuis tu vis un cauchemar par Al alors
ça faut aussi rétablir l'histoire c'est
que tuas un journaliste hier soir de pur
média pour pasciter qui m'appelle en me
disant tu es virer tes PMP moi je sais
très bien ce que nous on s'est dit et
avec toi avec le nel qui était pas du
tout le cas qui était dire attends j'ai
besoin de respirer 2 secondes parce que
ce que je v très complexe pour Valérie
aussi d'ailleurs et je lu dis non pas du
tout Valérie voilà on voulait pas non
non pas du tout juste laissez-moi je me
repose c'est très compliqué c'est très
compliqué pour pour moi pour ma maman tu
vois qui est une mère juive dans tous
les sens du terme qui a vécu un moment
un peu complexe voilà avec tout ça qui
connait pas trop les réseaux sociaux
mais qu'elle était traîné jeudi qui a
été voir qui a vu les menaces de mort
les machins et tout qui a fait un
malaise ou tu as des Malais de mort ta
maman a fait un malaise oui oui ben j'ai
tout eu en fait mais encore une fois
c'est c'est pas l'objectif on s'en fout
de raconter ça c'est ma vie perso voilà
c'est juste dire que je voilà je veux
mettre ça derrière moi j'ai appris ma
leçon il y a pas de problème euh je suis
pas débile je je comprends bien tout ce
que j'ai fait euh voilà j'apprends
encore une fois et et ça ne se
reproduira plus jamais ça t'était déjà
repruit jamais avant dans ma vie ça ne
se reproduira plus jamais après je
comprends tous les messages que j'ai
reçu aussi de gens qui étaient qui
étaient choqués avec qui j'ai discuté
parce que j'essayis de répondre à tout
le monde euh sur les réseau tu te dis
quoi à ce moment-là tu te dis euh je
vais faire un mot je vais faire un truc
qu'est-ce que tu dis mais en fait le
problème c'est que sur le moment euh on
s'est excusé même si géraldy n'a pas mes
excuses mais parce que c'était peut-être
maladoit c'est aussi toi qui a dit que
j'étais homo hein plus que moi qui dit
tout de suite mais
la réalité tu as dit oui que ça risque
rien mais en fait si ça risque quoi
qu'il arrive mais la réalité c'est que
je me suisqué sur le moment 10 minutes
après le lendemain le soir même et le
lendemain va aller que l'assistant était
clos et je m'étais dit je je vais arrêé
de communiquer ça sert à rien parce que
en fait si ça vient de moi quoi que je
dise c'est le délire donc c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça je te remercie que tu
as dit je vais prendre les choses en
main moi et et on va en parler ici mais
mais voilà
c'est voilà quoi c'est c'est le moment
le plus dur que ah bah oui oui ça c'est
sûr que c'est le moment le plus dur que
j'ai jamais m' vécu ma carrière parce
que dans la vie perso tu as toujours des
moments compliqués on va pas Valé
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que tuas dire à Alex
que c'est ça on s'est dit on s'est déjà
beaucoup parlé chose encore une fois je
je je redis c'est-à-dire
que Alex n'avait aucune intention et en
de de de de me faire du mal de de de que
je reçois que que je ressente un
sentiment d'humiliation comme ça ça pu
me traverser et cetera à ce moment-là ou
même après euh et je et je et je dis je
dis encore une fois il y a
toute une palette dans ce qu'on appelle
les agressions sexuelles il y a toute
une palette et
mett voilà je un abruti c'est
inapproprié c'est voilà mais j'avais
j'avais j'avais en face de moi un homme
qui était dans la contrition totale
ouais parce que encore une fois c'est
pas pareil c'est pas je suis pas je ne
suis pas une jeune femme qui était dans
le métro avec un type qui avait une
intention sexuelle et qui s'est frotté à
elle dans un but sexuel ou qui lui a mis
main aux fesses dans un but sexuel
j'avais un garçon qui a voulu faire une
vanne qui a dérapé qui s'en est
immédiatement excusé après j'ai pas vécu
le moment de façon formidable il l'a pas
vécu non plus comment tu as vécu le
déferlement sur Alex est-ce que tu dis
toi honnêtement au départ j'ai pas du
tout géré ce ce truc je me disais c'est
son problème c'est pas le mien après
tout pourquoi ça serait mon problème
ouais bien sûr et puis après j'ai de
l'empathie et je voyais le désar parce
que je te connais Valérie je sais que un
moment tu m'as appelé tu m'as dit c'est
vrai que voilà tu tu étais tu étais tu
étais pas bien aussi alors que c'était
toi qui avais qui qui a é d' Gest
inapoprié parce que la charge encore une
fois inversée c'est-àdire que j'ai pu
lire oui mais elle dansait col est serré
enfin c'està-dire je pense à tout ce
queon peut dire aussi à des femmes bon
euh euh
oui au début je me suis dit c'est t
problème c'est sa patate chaude il se
débrouille avec il avait cap parce que
on passe dans un moment un peu de colère
et puis après on a discuté et moi j'ai
de l'empathie et encore une fois je le
redis Alex n'était pas animé de
d'intention malveillante il voulait pas
m'humilier il voulait pas faire mal il
voulait s'amuser il s'est planté il
s'est trompé l'affaire est close tout va
bien il a toute mon amitié encore voilà
c'est ouais je sais qu'il est qu'il est
pas bien on passe à autre chose
mer mon Alex c'est vrai que Gill aussi
t'adore c'est vrai qu'on on était tous
mal après cette soir on te le dit parce
que tu as un garçon qu' qu'on adore
vraiment voilà on a on étit voilà c'est
vrai lui poser une question oui Alex
est-ce que vous avez tout de suite
mesuré que ce geste allait vous suivre
très longtemps est-ce que vous vous êtes
dit non seulement j'ai fait une
monstrueuse erreur mais je vais être
marqué par ça dorén avant non non non
mais j'ai compris sur le moment
évidemment tu dis ou là là c'est c'est
c'est typique le genre truc qui peut
aujourd'hui vraiment dégénérer et à
juste titre heureusement heureusement
que c'est la fin des mains au cul quoi
qu'il arrive de toute façon c'est quand
même une bonne chose dans l'histoire de
l'humanité donc je me suis ou là là oui
c'est vrai que ça peut dégénérer je
pensais pas que ça irait à ce niveau-là
et de cette puissance là mais après
c'est aussi une caisse de résonance ici
énorme tu vois donc on est sur
l'émission la plus vue du PAF matteindre
c'est aussi quelque part atteindre cyil
atteindre l'émission si quand tu vois le
nombre de de vu de n'importe quel
article fait sur ce truc c'est sidérant
c'est plus que ce que j'ai eu quand
j'étais nommé entraîneur enfin animateur
de ce que tu veux des grosses émissions
que j'ai pu faire dans mon histoire avec
des 7 millions de spectateurs ça n'a
rien à voir ça prend des proportions
hallucinantes donc évidemment je d pas
je démar ici je suis comme vous je sais
que vous avez tous eu à un moment donné
ou un autre de toute façon tous des
problèmes avec les réseaux sociaux et
oui donc je découvre l'empur de truc
donc je pensais pas que c'était à ce
point-là pour répondre à ta question je
savais très bien que j'avais fait une
connerie mais voilà à ce point-là non J
il y a plein de gens qui sur Twitter qui
disent ça va il a il a il a tué personne
il a violé personne qu'est-ce que tu dis
sû de la même manière qu'on on en a
beaucoup parlé effectivement je suis
absolument d'accord avec ce qui se dit
et et de la même manière qu'il y a une
hiérarchie c'est pas pareil un
attouchement une agression voilà mais le
problème aujourd'hui aussi et on en a
parlé c'est que bah une mauvaise blague
de texte on le dégage une main aux
fesses on dégage et ben un viol on
dégage donc en fait il y a il y a il y a
la même sanction pour tout le monde donc
j'incite quand même les gens aller
porter plainte pas dans ce cas-là bien
évidemment mais quand c'est vraiment une
agression sexuelle dans le métro et
qu'on a peur et et c'est vrai qu'il y a
pas de il y a pas de de hiérarchie en
fait aujourd'hui
dans Alex comment tu as vécu comment tu
as vécu cette semaine non mais la
semaine a été extrêmement complexe
probablement je dis la pire de ma vie
ever la pire de ta vie oui franchement
oui oui ça a été très très dur mais mais
c'était je savais aussi à quel point
c'était dur pour Valérie de voir des
mêmes partout et de me dire mais comment
je peux endiguer le truc qu'est-ce que
je peux faire après tout le mond disait
mais non mais ne dis rien parce que je
dis quelque chose tu remets une dans la
machine mais même aujourd'hui on va se
le dire tu vois je non non mais
aujourd'hui tu voilà on va on s dit cet
après-midi avec Valérie j'avais pas
envie que ça remette dans la machine je
disis mais c'est jeux plus de ça quoi
j'en peux plus en fait voilà donc je
suis fatigué mais c'est rien ça passé tu
as pas réussi à dormir pendant une
semaine non non c'est compliqué on dit
quoi tes proches par c'est surtout ma
mère qui qui m'inquiète voilà c'est mer
juif vraiment dans tous les sens du
termeeme maman Mo
aussi à Casablanca aussi comme comme toi
mais j'embrasse sa maman et j'en joins
tout le monde et encore une fois à avoir
un peu de de pondération et à savoir
qu'il y a des êtres humains lui et moi
et que par
ailleurs raison le problème c'estour
c'est toi ta famille moi ma famille
c'est ça le problème on se rend pas
compte tu vois il y a il y a une
hiérarchie dans les choses encore une
fois encore une fois Alex n'est pas un
frotteur dans le métro un frotteur dans
le métro n'est pas un ouaisur ENF il y a
des hiérarchies dans les voilà et et
donc il y a des degrés aussi dans le
dans les réactions qu'on doit qu'on doit
avoir et malheureusement il paye aussi
enfin d'une certaine manière aussi tu
payes aussi pour l'époque c'est-à-dire
que avec ce geste per te déplacer tu
l'as dit 200 fois il y a aucune ambiguïé
et passons à autre chose si on normalise
ce geste là à au niveau de tes PMP qui
regarde par des jeunes alors qu'on parle
de harcèlement on parle de violence et
tout ça et que il y a une gamine qui
elle par ailleurs subit par exemple des
des mains au fesses répét dans son école
et surtout d'ailleurs au niveau des
réactions si tu au niveau des réactions
j'ai eu moi beaucoup de gens audessus de
30 ans m'ont dit oh là là mais qu'est-ce
que c'est que ce délire c'est et tout et
c'est surtout les
jeunes des jeunes de 20 ans 25 ans qui
m'écrivent et à qui voilà je je discute
avec parce que j'essaie de répondre à
tout le monde voilà mais mais
effectivement c'est surtout c'est c'est
un problème générationnel tu as eu
beaucoup de coup de fil bah des coups de
fil oui pas mal gens qui disaient quoi
comment ça va ou pouroui ça non surtout
des gens qui essayent de se renseigner
de savoir comment tu vas et comment ça
se passe parce que je avou que j'étais
vraiment débordé par le truc ouais c'est
ça voilà tuas tu as joué au thâre ce
weekend non j'ai j'ai rien fait ce
weekend rien fait non j' essayer de
partir même et puis ça ça a rien
arranger donc voilà ouais donc là tu
avais envie là tu as envie de de couper
tu avais envie de couper complètement
oui oui d'ailleurs c'est ce que j'ai dit
à ce journaliste qui du coup a dit il
arrête la télé il veut partir au
Guatemala il fa des vaches non voilà
c'est juste que j'ai besoin
tranquillement de me remettre de ça que
se remettre et voilà ouais ça a été un
ouais ça a été un moment très compliqué
tuas tu as regardé les réseaux tu
regardes encore tu arrêté non ben moi
j'essaie de regarder parce que j'essaie
de répondre ouais mais non voilà les
trucs d'une extrême violence voilà je
réponds pas bien sûr les menaces de mort
les condamnation les machin tout ce que
tu veux je réponds pas mais après les
gens qui sont qui sont choqués à qui je
peux discuter j'essaie de discuter avec
eux et voilà il arrêté on le sait voilà
je ferai plus jamais ça ever ah oui et
puis encore une fois je l'avais jamais
fait avant c'est ça le plus fou c'est
que de ma vie j'ai jamais mis la main au
cul à personne mais ever voilà JAAC
c'est c'est on s'est parlé le lendemain
ou le sur lendemain je sais plus tu m' m
tu m'as appelé et on a partagé nos nos
impressions de de début de chroniqueur
parce que c'est vrai que c'est c'est une
fausse d'une certaine
façon ça peut aller très vite ça peut
déraper très vite et il y a une mise en
abîme qui est très forte on a tu as
raison
une on parle on est on on taille
beaucoup les les gens et on est
impitoyable avec avec des politiques
avec les juges et cetera et on essaie de
le faire le plus justement possible donc
on ne peut pas ne pas le faire pour nous
c'est ça exactement on a on a ce devoirl
absolument au jeunes et en plus nous
globalement on est plutôt d'une
génération où on aurait tendance à dire
bon c'est pas trop grave sauf qu' on ne
doit plus dire ça on sait qu'on ne peut
plus dire ça et donc on sait et et Alex
Savit pas qu'on ne peut plus c'est qu'on
ne doit bien sûr c'est ce que je dis
quand je disais tout à l'heure non mais
sais j'ai une fille qui a 25 ans je
parle avec elle elle me dit papa c'est
pas 2023 en fait donc arrête avec ça
c'est pas 2023 donc moi je sens bien je
je le sens et quand j'ai eu Alex jeis
juste terminer làdessus
je sais que ça n'est pas toi et je
voudrais que voilà je voulais juste le
dire par amitié mais c'est déconnecté
évidemment de ce geste de tout ce qu'on
dit qui doit avoir valeur d'exemple à
l'égard des jeunes et à l' Gard de tout
le monde c'est évident Alex tu as envie
de quoi aujourd'hui là bah rien de me
dire que c'est le point final de cette
histoire c'est fini et que
aprèsre sujet exactement voilà plus on
s'est éclaté avec toi je te dis la
vérité on adore quand tu avec nous et
tout le monde t'adore dans l'équipe
vraiment tu as été vraiment accueilli
par tout le monde parce que tu es un
garçon avec qui on adore être donc c'est
vrai que voilà même nous ça nous a peiné
Valérie voulait terminer oui non je je
voulais juste dire à tous ceux qui se
disaient outré tout en partageant en
même temps la capture d'écran avec le
gros plan avec la photo cette forme
d'hypocrisie en disant on est outré mais
on on fait quand même circuler la photo
voilà bah si vous êtes vraiment outré
vous enlevez la photo des réseaux et moi
moi je voudrais juste dire à ceux aussi
qui sont tombés sur Valérie euh pour lui
dire oui c'est quoi ta réaction tu
rigoles et cetera euh Valérie c'est
grande fille Valérie elle est
extrêmement intelligente elle sait
exactement où elle va et ce qu'elle doit
faire donc elle a elle a de conseils à
recevoir de personne donc les donneurs
de leçon qui sont venus sur Valérie et
qui ont commencé à insulter Valérie
parce qu'elle avait pas eu pour eux la
bonne réaction écoutez occupez-vous de
vous et laissz Valérie gérer sa vie et
gérer sa carrière elle le fait très bien
depuis des années et des années donc ça
moi les donneurs de le son une fois de
plus occupez-vous de votre cul voilà
c'est tout ce que jeavais vous dire et
je pense que c'est c'était le moment de
le dire
voilà ma Valérie ça va toi ma chérie
ouis ça va très bien non mais ça va
c'est VO et Alex Alex vraiment je te dis
Valérie même elle était pas bien parce
que elle t'aime énormément et que au
départ elle était très énervée après toi
je te le dis comme tout le monde et
après bah elle s'est dit mine de rien
c'est pas Alex c'était voilà et elle a
elle a voilà même elle elle était très
triste de voilà de de ce qui s'était
passé beaucoup de soirées avec lui mais
pas
forcément les soir je je voulais parler
justement des des soirée ouais il y a je
tavir un cadre général souvent il y a
deux soirées dans une soirée ouais il y
a tu vas à un cocktail tu vas un
vernissage tu vas faire une émission de
télé et cetera et là il y a déjà une
possibilité de faire le con bien sûr et
puis après il y a les gens que tu aimes
bien que tu retrouves ailleurs je qu-ce
qu'il y a non non allez-y in continuez
continuez rien fait et ensuite tu peux
retrouver
il a dit j'ai rien faiti Michel ah mais
j'ai rien fait alors il y a deux types
de et donc la deuxième partie souvent
plus plus intime c'est tu te retrouves
entre amis de de différents milieux et
là c'est plus intime et beaucoup plus
comment dire sportif ouais ça veut dire
quoi sportif dis-moi la vérité bah je
vous laisse imaginer on fait du sport
non non c'est quoi on fait du sport
sexuel du sport ouais
sexuel il y a des chambres il y a du
sport non non mais je veux dire il se
passe des choses oui ouioui c'est quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il veux dire là myiam il
par des k sex non ah non moi j'ai jamais
fait ça
ah mais à mon époque ça existait pas les
cam non mais c'était à quelle fréquence
ces soirées là oh ça peut arriver
plusieurs fois par semaine non ça TRZ
pas les mecs mais le problème c'est que
la soirée est en de jours ah ouais d'c à
la soirée cé en de jours la soirée il a
des soiré qui durent de jours absolument
et trois fois par semaine se fait donc
tous les jours semaine voilà
incroyable incroyable euh juste Claude
euh c'est c'est non mais ces soirées il
y avait il y avait de la de la drogue il
y avait de la drogue bien sûr j'arrive
pas de le dire non tu dis que ça faisait
du sport bah oui bah du sport dans Je
qu'on s'amusait alors il y avait de
l'alcool oui c'est ça que tu veux savoir
il y avait de l'alcool pierre palmat
faisait venir enfin aurais je vais
utiliser le conditionnel faisait venir
aussi donc de la drogue mais aussi des
escortes boys et c'est là que ça a
dégénéré euh moi je je j'ai j'ai fait
énormément de soirées avec lui mais
c'était plutôt se retrouve au resto à
l'amazonial on allait euh chez nos amis
Tony et je sais plus et Bertrand et
Bertrand oui pai à son âme pai à son âme
oui et on allait au banane à café et
cetera là toute cette partie de soirée
on les faisait ensemble d'accord et moi
les quelques potes que que que je
connaissais ou euh dans ce cas-là ceux
qui qui m'intéresse un peu plus que
d'autres je le donn rendez-vous chez moi
ou chez eux et là c la de après il y
avait l'after l'fter qui démarre à 11h
du matin le lendemain de la fête et qui
continue jusqu'à le après jusqu'à la
soirée voilà jusqu'à la soirée où là il
faut non non ça peut durer de 3 jours
hein la soirée de 3 jours mais il y a
pas besoin il y avait pas de pinulle ça
je veux te dire de mon temps en tout cas
ouais et c'est à dire que moi il y a
très longtemps que c'est fini ça non
mais tuas r tu fais ce que tu
veux si j' conseille à vous donner ceux
qui ont jamais essayé n'essayez jamais
bien sûr par le nombre de conneries ça
m'a fait
faire je peux vous dire que le sait ou
je dérouille maintenant ouais vrai opéré
fois c'est un pote vraiment un bon très
bon pote claud c'éit mon premier j'ai
opéré qu fois en 2 ans et tous les
problèmes que j'ai respiratoire
card urologique et cetera urologique
j'ai t problème là ils viennent d'après
mes médecinsneries ils viennent de ça et
ça c'est les conséquences et toutes les
conneries qu'on fait dans le métier
parce que quand tu es en forme et
quelqu'un te casse les bonbons h euh tu
lu envois pas un courrier dire viens tu
lui fous dans la gueule je que tu as
envie de lui dire quoi tu es pas très
diplomate ouais alors tu regrettes ouais
d'avoir été je pense que je regrette
rien ouais comme il dit je regrette rien
mais si c'était à refaire je feraai
certainement pas le même chemin ouais et
je ne vivrai pas cette deième partie to
vois tu aurais mieux fait de rester avec
moi tu as vu ouais était tu vois on m'a
interdit de raconter une anecdote donc
je la raconterai pas quoi avec moi ah
moi j'ai pas fait de ah non non non att
stop stop ils vont je vais me faire
engueuler mais non non tuas jamais pris
de dog sauf que tu t'es jamais rendu
compte que j'en prenais ouais c'est vrai
je te jour que c'est vrai bah oui parce
que moi on est parti 8 jours ensemble à
Lyon ouais je faisais mon spectacle
exactement après je dormais pas avec toi
au bouiboui non mais on passait on pass
quelques heures tous les jours ah oui
mais oui ou enfin tu sais moi j'avais
commencé avant qu'on se voit ouais moi
je sais moi j'étais j'étais lui il voit
rien du tout et tout comme quoi faut
faire gaffe parce que la drogue fait
faire aussi des choses qui sont pas
honnêtes pas sincèr on trahit des gens
quand tu étais avec moi tu tu tu t'en
fout t PL de PIF oui oui oui je sais
ouis mais tu sais je le voyais pas du
tout je te vois ça un peu speed je te
casse pas non mais c'est vrai he mais un
bon message de prévention c'est mais tu
tu te souviens quand on avait fait le
spectacle au Trévise ouais avec Stéphane
g et jérme rev mes amis
ouiembrasse a un moment j'ai disparu du
spectacle non pas j'étais plus co
producteur ouais j'étais complètement à
l'Ouest c'est ça il te l'ont jamais dit
bah non tu sais moi je faisais mon truc
non mais c'est vrai mais c'est vrai tu
sais que je t'aime et que c'est vraiment
un ami de longue date Claude voilà et
c'est vrai que Claude il regrette il
regrette tout ça CIS oui puis surtout
n'y allit pas tu as raison moi je suis
un repenti ouais et aujourd'hui si si si
on me le propose tu touches plus rien là
tu touches plus rien si vois un petit
coup de temps en temps c'est d'accord
ouais coup ça applaudit non mais les
gars Josi alors Jean-Michel
Jean-Michel je l'ai jamais caché moi je
suis beaucoup sorti dans ma vie j'ai
fréquenté les soirées parisiennes et je
j'en ai beaucoup trop fait voilà à tous
les niveaux mais le le cercle là où ça
présente un cercle infernal c'est qu'on
fait la fête de la nuit ces produits
stupéfiants vous aide à faire la nuit
parce que ça vous excite ça vous donne
envie de de faire le con et cetera et ça
vous empêche de dormir aussi même quand
vous arrêtez vous arrêtez la fête à 5h
du matin si vous avez consommé de la
drogue jusqu'à 5h du matin vous
n'arrivez pas à dormir même si vous
savez vous pouvez dormir pouz Pasir mais
malheureusement vous travaillez le
lendemain et pour être en for le
lendemain vous reprenez des substance
pour pour pas que ça se voit dans votre
entourage professionnel et donc vous
retapez mais si vous retapez dans la
journée ça vous donne envie de continuer
à taper et donc du coup vous continuez
toutes Je je m'en suis jamais caché
malheureusement je suis tombé dedans un
moment j'en suis sorti bien heureusement
mais c'est vrai V un moment mais dans
toutes les soirées parisiennes ceux qui
disent qu'ils l'ont jamais vu ça ils
sont vous poser à tous les deux pas
dangereux c'est pas dangereux pour les
les les les stars des stars comme ça de
de de de faire appel à des des dealers
et cetera c'est une connerie ah oui
parce que après derrière estce qu'il y a
pas des problèmes moi j'ai jamais fait
app appel à dealer du showbe ouais faut
être con il y a des dealers du showbiz
oui des dealers des VIP quoi genre quoi
ou jamais je suis toujours passé par des
connaissances dans le showbiz mais ça
peut ton attaché de presse ça peut être
un technicien sur un plateau to ouis ou
pas ici
he mais ça revent au même he ou par du
local non mais s revient pas au même
c'est quand le dealer il tombe avec un
carnet avec 20 ministres 30 députés des
chanteurs dans les soiré il y avait des
ministre bien sûr ça il y a eu des gens
politiques très connus ouais non dans
les soirées en train de faire des tu fas
pas dire les noms hein non mais non mais
il y a une époque dans les années 80 où
c'était une substance qui était réservée
un peu au IP c'était rock roll et 80 y a
eu même là dans les ah oui oui il y
avait des hommes politiques oui des
députés en exercice des députés en
exercice oui en exercice qui faisaient
des exercices ou qui sont là en exercice
et je me souviens que dans une clinique
où j'ai été où je suis allé de mon
propre plingé je veux dire pour arrêter
il y avait des des députés qui venait
dormir à la clinique le soir pour le
pour se contrôler pour pas faire le con
la nuit non ah ouais mais dans toute la
France il y a pas une soirée en France
où j'ai été invité et CETA où il y a pas
quelqu'un dans la soiré qui vous propose
quelque chose il y en a partout c'est
plus du tout une drogue un peu de un peu
obscur de tabou des riches et cetera
même dans les soirées étudiantes en a il
en a tellement pas cher maintenant on a
vu on a vu tu crois que tu trouves
pierre palmat si sil on est là
aujourd'hui c'est un mec qui a un talent
exceptionnel c'est c'est ça qu'il a
foutu dedans faut dire aux jeunes qui
nous regardent à tous les les jeunes les
moins jeunes qui nous
regard le problème c'est que moi je me
suis arrêté il y a une vingtaine
d'années et lui il a continué il se
serait arrêté il y a 20 ans ce serait le
roi du monde aujourd'hui je parle son
talent il y a un animateur moi très
connu je peux pas dire son nom qui m'a
dit un jour il m'a m'a dit tu vois il y
a des gens il m'ont dit Anouna il prend
de la c la C j'ai dit si Anouna prit de
la coque il pourrait pas faire une
quotidienne pendant 12 ans c'est
impossible il dit moi m'a dit moi j'ai
pas pu j'ai pas pu tenir entien il m'a
dit c'est impossible j'ai dévissé j'ai
j'ai dérouillé parce que j'ai voilà
j'étais j'étais voà malheureus par au
bout d'un moment ça tout casse c'est ça
en fait tout casse non mais c'est vrai
tu regrettes aujourd'hui Claude
franchement oui oui tuas eu des gros
problèmes de santé à cause de ça c'est
je l' vu en ce moment
ouais je dois me opéré dans un mois je
opéré il y a un mois PERP là je te jure
ça me rend fou parce que je' je t'aime
tellement mon CLA tu es un mec tu avais
un talent exceptionnel de producteur tu
es et je vous dis je suis pas mort
encorein mais je sais système un écro en
direct et honnêtement si vous en prenez
je le sauraai depuis longtemps mais je
l'aurais depuis bien longtemps notamment
quand on fait des directs enfin des
émissions et des primes après et vous
quittez jamais le plateau vous restez
toujours ici la pub vous restez ici vous
prenez une note vous déconnez avec nous
et ceter vous en sur un prime parfois il
y a 5 6 he de tunnel d'émission comme ça
en live en direct comme ça quelqu'un qui
prend je peux vous dire TR fois il sort
il va au toilettes il en prend il
revient après
animurs c'est qui
encoreingilles c'est la soirée oui c'est
non il y a des animateurs très connus
qui sont qui sont plus là aujourd'hui je
parle pas de la rue forcément mais je
parle d'un mec qui faisit des grandes
émissions hebdomadair familial qui entre
porter qure fois l'après-midi du ou C
fois du du plateau ouais ou pour se
revigorer
ouis c'est ouis c'est fou c'est alors
c'est le cadreur qui te
parl un
connard non je rigole non non mais
Claude aujourd'hui sur sur l'affaire
Pierre Palmade est-ce que tu l'as eu au
téléphone est-ce que tu as essayé
de qu'il a essayé de te parler non non
non non non non non j'ai a eu énormément
de gens qui m'ont qui ont trouvé ma
position quand je suis venu je sais plus
si c'était en avril mai ouais ça ouais
euh qu' on trouvé que c'était cétait une
position mesurée honnête ouais bien sûr
ça me fait de la peine mais pour moi les
victimes c'est la famille est-ce qu'il y
a d'autres pierre palmad en en substance
voilà qui voilà d'autres humoristes ou
d'autres personnes qui sont en ce moment
que tu as envie de leur dire vous êtes
en danger et vous allez tu vois des
trucs ouais moi les ns bien sûr moi je
fréquente plus depuis que j'habite dans
mon petit l'IDE à Cassis sous Sénat je
l'ai casé he madame le Maire donc depuis
que j'habite là-bas ais à Cassis sous
Sénat don je disais et bien et bien je
je rencontre j'ai quelques copines
copains artistes qui viennent mais c'est
pas Fabien Tibo qui m'amène de la couque
à la maison qu'est-ce si si tu tu avais
pierre pierre Palma au téléphone ou si
tu le voyais tu lui dirais quoi je
dirais faut assumer maintenant non mais
tu tu tu tu lui as dit un moment toi tu
as arrêté quand toi les conneries
qu quand j'ai fait ce livre là que vous
trouverez plus mais li brisé déjà le
titre ouais euh et a combien de temps ça
fait quoi 15 20 ans et tu l'as pas dit à
Pierre un moment fais gaffe moi voilà
j'ai arrêté on je voyait moins déjà à
cette époque là on se croisait comme
avec Jean-Marie on se régulièrement
croisé toujours ouais poteau et tout
comment ça va mais on passait plus des
des grands moments ensemble g vous
regrettez de pas lui avoir dit faut
arrêter à un moment vous auriez dû être
plus directif non je prenais avec lui à
ce momentl donc tu vas pas dire mec qui
t'en prend faut arrêter c'est pas bien
et
vas-y mais là récemment vous auriez pu
enfin je veux dire avant que ça arrive
ces dernières années vous auriez pu
avoir on était plus en contact mais il
écoutait personne il éc pas je crois qu'
attention déjà moi j'écoutais pas grand
monde ouis ou j'ai fait 20 ans de moins
de de trajet ouais mais je pense que 20
ans de plus tu dois quand même les
neurones qui sont tu réagis plus comme
tout le monde totalement je sais pas ce
que tu en penses je Marie
oui ben le gros problème c'est que à
cette époque là comme comme l'a dit
Jean-Michel bon il y avait la fête
l'après la fête donc au lieu de de se
coucher comme n'importe quelle personne
un peu ivre à 5h du matin tu as eu ton
compte quand tu as de de la cocaïne à
midi tu es frais comme un gardon quoi
après avoir bu une bouteille de whisky
en plus du du clafouti donc c'est
effectivement un truc il y a un moment
où la plupart des gens disent ben faut
stopper parce que ou demain je travaille
ou après-demain je travaille donc tu
fais stop le stop de l'époque c'était un
lexomil et tu fais de do tu t'endors et
et le lendemain est une autre journée
pierre n'a pas d'autrre journées pour
lui il en a qu'une à vivre et tout le
temps jusqu'à ce qui tombe par terre ou
qui déambule dans la rue sachant même
plus comment il s'appelle c'est-à-dire
son son problème c'est le stop euh à
Pierre lui a dit tu disais tout à
l'heure personne lui a dit on lui a dit
on lui a rabâché marriel Robin et moi
tous les autres a dit stop il faut là tu
es haut tu es au deuxème jour il faut tu
tu prends un truc tu dors et puis après
tu verras si tu fais une autre fête un
autre jour non ça ne s'arrêtait jamais
j'ai même jamais compris comment
physiquement il pouvait tenir si tu veux
au tout début de ces affaires là ENF
quand on se connaissait donc il y a 30
ans on se disait pierre Palm dans 2 ans
il est mort quoi ah ouais ça ça on le
disait déjà je disais vraiment ça hein
disais c'est il y a des trucs tu sais
t'en servir puis y a d'autres tu vois
par exemple il faut pas oublier
Jean-Marie que pendant cette période là
où c'était quand même bien déjanté il
faisait 200 spectacles dans l'année oui
oui bien sûr comment il faisait alors
pour faire exp ah bah il les faisait
hein ENF il y en a certains qui étaient
un peu plus long que d'autres sûr ouais
euh il y a des sies qui duraiit 8
minutes au lieu de 4 ah ouais bon mais
moi je l'accompagnais très souvent puis
après après c'est Pascal Guillaume qui
l'a accompagné aussiou c'est la phrase
de de Jean-Marie qui disait à l'époque
on disait dans 2 ans Pierre palmad il
est mort ça le disait ouais ouis
exactement on disait comment il pourrait
tenir et pourtant parce que tout le
monde tout le monde s'arrête au bout
disons de 30 HE quoi de ribouing mais
lui il faisait des paquets de 72 voilà
et ça c'est pas ça peut pas ten mais moi
je reconnais qu'à l'époque j'en prenais
avec lui donc je ça tu nous l'as dit
hein j'ai oui mais je le dis ouais donc
tu peux pas dire à un mec de pas en
prendre si toi tuen prends quoi en tout
cas moi j'avais pas la for tu peux dire
bah moi j'arrête ouais c'est ça j'arrête
on se verra jeudi
prochain ces valeurs organoleptiqu
excusez-moi
ouais on vous entend pas mon chéri c'est
c'est que ce que je voulais dire c'est
que il y a un an j'ai eu un accident
très grave qui m'a complètement
paralyséord mais grâce à vous j'ai pu
survivre vous m'avez complètement aidé à
guérir tous les jours à l'hôpital je
voyais votre émission et un jour après
plusieurs mois d'entraînement j'ai enfin
pu me mettre
debout marcher et enfin éteindre cette
émission de merde tout seul vraiment je
voulais vous remercier des vra
la d'accord tu veux faire quoi en fait
tu veux rester tu veux partir je juste
pas faire une crise non c'est mieux vous
êtes TR potes très bien allez potes
barrezvous voilà alors bon voilà donc
hier beaucoup tout le monde en a parlé
après il a fait son petit buzz Théo euh
je crois qu'il va venir nous voir dans
un instant d'ailleurs Théo audace euh
Gilles qu'est-ce que tu en as pensé j'ai
détesté franchement honnêtement j'ai
détesté il a réussi son coup mais euh il
a réussi son coup parce qu'on est sympa
voilà parce qu'on parce que vous avez
été très sympa vous l'avez écouté moi je
pense à tous les gens hier il y a des
gens qui m'ont écrit qui sont
agoraphobes euh des gens qui ont des des
béquill qui sont malades qui ont eu des
accidents de la vie des vrais et je
trouve qu'il s'est moqué d'eux d'une
manière qui moi me choque et me fait mal
pour eux tous et eux beaucoup m'ont dit
nous on s'est senti mal parce qu'on a
pas le droit de faire ça sur notre dos
voilà ce qui me gêne alors c'est une qui
a déjà été faite plein de fois sur les
réseaux il a pas Moné du tout en fait à
la base c'était sur un twitch sur Ryana
cama regardez il y a notamment un
streamer qui a été piégé et là déjà
c'était c'était c'était plus drôle
regardez ça fait maintenant 3 ans que je
te suis je suis paraplégi et que je suis
tes stream dans mon lit d'hôpital merci
beaucoup euh bryler la vie n'était pas
facile tous les jours là-bas et mes
parents me mettaient t stream pour me
remonter le moral ça donnitement de
motivation pour recommencer à marcher
aujourd'hui grâce à Dieu je suis en
parfaite santé et je peux enfin me lever
tout seul pour couper
té voilà alors après bon c'est voilà ça
c'était un peu plus marrant et alors
c'est un tiktokeur qui a l'habitude de
faire des vannes des pranks vous a fait
une compile sachez que ce que vous allez
voir là ce sont ses meilleures vidéos
malheureusement question du jour réponds
au téléphone devant des inconnus en
criant le plus fort possible allô je
t'entends pas essaye des baskets dans un
magasin et fait semblant de de partir en
courant jeentraîner à la course tombe
devant des inconnus et chaque fois qu'il
te relève retombe parfois je per un peu
non non non non non reste reste reste on
va appeler quelquun embrasse le crâne
d'un chauve que tu ne connais pas juste
avoir un petit bisou de votre crâne s'il
vous plaît je vous en supplie Monsieur
sidanou que le BIS sur le Crâ c'est pas
possible bon alors voilà donc il avait
aucun problème pour marcher en fait Tho
oui non mais je trouve ça nul c'est le
c'est en fait c'est gre Guillotin de
Aliexpress c'est nul c'est pas drôle
c'est raté se moquer du handicap c'est
nul son je trouve que la blague était
complètement ratée en plus quand elle
était faite encore sur twitch bon ça
aller mais là c'était pas bien et et et
franchement prendre en age encore une
fois une émission pour ça abuser de
votre votre gentillesse c'est n'importe
quoi et ce que j'aime pas en plus c'est
qu'il critique l'émission c'est qu'
vient dire que c'est une émission de
merde à la rigueur si tu veux passer à
la télé fais un truc drôle et si tu veux
qu'on qu'on t'invite dans cette émission
fais un truc pour pour être invité mais
pour les bonnes raisons fais pas de la
mer comme ça ouais c'est vrai un j'ai
trouvé ça j'ai trouvé ça raté et
franchement un peu de la merde j' c'est
un peu de la merde en plus moi il m'a
fait de la peine au départ ça nous a à
l'aise Eton les gens r peut-être pas
comp jouer avec vos émotions c'est ça
qui est pas bien et avec les émotions
des gens là et de tous les
téléspectateurs vous inquiétez pas j'ai
son adresse les gens les gens le public
les téléspectateurs effectivement les
gens qui travaillent pour l'agence du
public c'est qu'il a donné des béquill
et cetera enfin vraiment se [__] de la
gueule des gens et on le voit aussi dans
ses pièges que c'est pas un ressort
comique drôle il est vraiment là pour
humilier les gens et c'est pas bien je
trouve moi pe c'était sympa peutêre
ouais non mais je l'ai vu en direct donc
donc moi je suis vraiment offusqué et et
en fait c'est sérieux en fait le
handicap c'est un sujet sérieux et et
donc trois choses rapidement la première
c'est que c'est pas drôle il a voulu
faire du buzz le problème c'est que le
buzz ça dure une heure ou deux voir 2
jours les blessures qu'on peut faire aux
gens ça peut durer des mois des années
donc déjà il y a il y a un écart à à
prendre en compte la deuxième chose j'ai
lu que Sophia disait que c'était de
l'art contemporain mais c'est de l'art
pour la connerie
plutôt dit ça
dit ça relève de l'art contemporain mais
elle elle
est plus c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
une
guign alors moi je lui réponds à Ceop
gentiment j'ai rien contre elle elle
aurait dû s'arrêter à con c'est l'art
pour les cons voilà ça c'est le deuxième
point et enfin le troisème point
puisqu'on parle d'humour oui on peut
rire de tout disait pierre des proches
mais pas avec n'importe qui et en
l'occurrence les personnes en situation
de handicap ça fait 10 cours préparés
mais c'est hyper c'est h naturel on peut
pas rire de de tout avec tout le monde
parce que moi c'est bah des blagues
comme ça j'ai vécu longtemps à l'école
et même après dans l'adolescence et et
voilà donc on peut rire quand ça sert la
cause et que et que bon il y a de
l'autodérision là c'est pas drôle c'est
malaisant et puis je pense à toutes les
personnes qui vraiment galèrent parce
que le handicap c'est pas que l'
sururdité c'est pas que les handicaps
visible moi je suis j'ai un handicap qui
est invisible aujourd'hui il ne se voit
pas mais donc du coup voilà il faut un
peu de bienveillance dans ce monde et
surtout notre génération on a un rôle à
jouer les jeunes bah d'essayer de de
montrer que voilà on a on a pas un 2.0
mais un cerveau un peu un peu constitué
voilà c'est le message que
[Applaudissements]
j'envoie